Assalamu alaykum.
Hey Zach, it was a phenomenal.
Yes, sir, Vena.
Either…
You know who
Allahay, alhamdulillah.
Nobody.
And da-hwarke.
I will sprint in my…
President Hamdulillah.
If people, alhamdulillah.
Okay.
Uh, this is Eiffel Vidyul, another group.
Palsy, man. My shoulder off.
So can I get the numbers once
and cut the initiative.
Oh, yeah, I mean, the whole…
I shared it with my group Italian.
Right. More so on, uh…
Um…
Yeah, Annie, uh…
Insha'Allah, if Jani, please…
Feel free and into, uh…
Amen and, um…
When, uh…is.
Um…
sticky notes.
I share screen sane.
Posito? Ratching.
Where…
What went good, what went bad? Recommendations, our actions, webinar lobby?
retrospective of the taqhariyah.
Fine, um…
El tajayo el beta el mo que ni bajaga movilidad. Teni.
And then not?
Um…
cannot be presented to Shogulu.
No feedback?
con el insights will battle discovery phase.
Uh, and hypothesis had to be any hypothesis in Muqtalifa, recommendations, okay, I don't integrate them all about.
Uh, the bail actions, yeah.
Fadacanal approach.
Can Anandina muskilas target segments.
So…
In a stand-up meeting, I had senti.
discussion on Elizabeth
Hmm.
I think is world discovery. How should I collaborate with my colleagues
We and Nana
0, which means zero.
So…
This is from my Indiana. Sarahamas totagitan beltas su sa lamarita ita breakdown.
But let's get shipped there and let's succeed, but that time will
Squares.
none other than none of them
We also…
Okay.
We have a laha
When I'm a typing my claim.
about local, uh…
Link…
Yeah, they'll, uh… the, uh, no syllah?
put down his ideas,
I'm not gonna…
or something. Taib, uh…
Uh, when, uh…
wouldn't… I mean…
The challenger, of course, uh…
Okay, I'm an additional
Okay.
And I'm about to add a certainty. About to my brain is vague?
All right.
Uh…
But you…
Zenab, how about the check in?
on the recommendations.
Um, solo…
Um, the service.
Dr. Hagamis, um,
Yeah.
Bismazan…
Ms.
Uh, Monsieur.
Okay.
Uh, I'll have a task form.
We'll be there, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Uh, you can…
They cannot… video can…
hat feedback.
Um, approach.
How's our approach, um…
Again, Mrs. I would…
must be shock to him.
Hello, everybody.
The Hagathania, is it?
Nazocrine.
Uh, mich.
Ron. Yes, sir.
mechan wood.
Okay.
Uh, Damien.
feedback, uh…
Or I had them tagging them, so…
ASRO and had the…
Yanni?
Anita, ma'am.
Okay, okay, so clockwork.
Any fish?
Of course, must impact me.
Okay.
However, it details.
So, here's the hint, I was like, hey, here's a…
part of the…
A data title.
Great.
Okay.
Mesh.
Yeah, I mean, okay.
How are you?
Hello.
Yes, I'm gonna react.
Um, okay.
Get up a link.
Oh, okay, I thought it calls.
So, help.
Other tasks.
Y'allavir.
I mean, Havid…
I grow.
I mean, um…
I would love him a task.
Uh, by the group.
I did not know, I am not…
Hmm.
A multi-action total.
Oh no.
Any wildlife.
It can quickly turnaround of.
Uh, eh?
Thank you, Keith. Oh, sa, ta?
On the left, uh, in the eyes are.
But you can…
Are you? I'm him.
gigden.
Yeah, and the oriental task…
Hmm.
Feedback leaner? Mit den ku datasheet.
i.
Yet a little bit less.
I'll actually give them.
Valon?
And yeah,
Is bet an answer.
managed.
responded to Sahama Khalmaina.
?
Okay, the atmosphere…
Admirzool?
Iowa.
One minus…
Okay. My feet…
I'm sorry.
Hey.
Hmm.
elite mentor?
Uh…
And
Okay. Some of these, and a couple boardroom.
Go ahead.
This is optional.
Uh, move to go to forward.
Voce config le, um…
BRD.
circle.
Team.
Wham…
Fadin Alto was, um…
Baldu?
Okay.
Hey.
I'm sure I was like…
Okay.
If I…
But we'll… we'll…
el…
el perfect scenario.
in life is not perfect holes,
Deep research, Mahalesh,
at least…
a similar.
at Tekiani, uh, companies,
Nasrah, wok, akok.
hat Arabak minerwoka.
El quantitative var, bordo, um…
Um, as I'll… as a hobby, as a Zamai Lima, I have a group,
As a lady for the online course obliget.
fair…
In fact, insights.
can help.
I have found.
Mmm.
And I hated the competitor.
I wouldn't know.
So… so.
Okay.
With Brent.
That's a good point, good point.
il viel experience.
And that a represental experience.
I'm at the basement to present the Hagatania for Calamonto.
Mm-hmm.
Andel 2.
Uh… wallahi!
Yeah, and he… a high one. I hire a lot of, uh…
Yes.
But my love for the…
numerical data quantitative data,
Fotosque.
So, Martina?
Mia, may ya.
May I show data. One gifted hypothesis is mining an amaltahaktin il ulan na na kelentus havi.
One of the healthy fee courses la cometosuio courses, la lakopel finance, o quad courseanama kemeltus, different courses, badeleine umian.
We ship Shotty tank can,
Can you expect living on board with Tabac courses.tatu.
Bisaba been in frequent in A. Curses.
Yeah, I mean, uh…
La Hawaii
e-learning.
Tim Shiri, you know.
at least, hopefully.
Okay.
But Tiffy Mike was half of your kalening mebaishandin mush keftenli mushkilprints.
Our school online learning, Colombi wago unafir much kila.
what's wood.
They have the comment
issue. Penhina
with Amarzu el fill meeting, Lauren.
online courses.
Let me…
non-profit organization.
But how I could be a business
We ban the revenue stream
But this is why an ankadin catch.
Okay, all hija.
Okay.
I thought God was good title. Misfil as well.
We talk Ba'u.
I'm going to talk about.
Hi, Alina and Roda.
My question was, ha, follows.
El…
And I bet.
Chief Learning Officer,
El ciel calculem.
for when to have to present to…
el internship.
Where…
learners.
O masca, um…
fedetta,
In V, in Nesbus drop off,
They'll insight.
Messi? Then inside the engiven, the guy Kagivanadla.
And it's not a valida.
Platform data?
user journey I will experience.
I had to enroll the course.
But so, Baldwiniven.
course a la Coursera.
a uma.
Family?
Fija.
owner.
Okay.
Kalini.
Is there any question?
Ele…
a learning experience or product experience, which I climb.
And our concept is video-based.
self-paced, video-based learning.
Well, I can walk yani.
A valid feedback. Well, I evaluate feedback?
He'll experience.
the assets, our data…
I mean, in higheah?
of Koku, I will, um…
Andul…
detail-oriented, any…
Had this any…
Honey, so I have a habit of a
will, uh…
situ?
Get them.
business-oriented.
valid. Okay, not a valid.
We'll make sure about that.
fill projects?
Sprinter games, or no.
Again.
it's going to be.
And leave it by 10 games.
Hmm.
Understood and passion.
Giftable other vehicle, and Amazon underway in Week 3.
field courses with art and product management, and alternate handy type. Week 3, il la fossil fuel content week 2.
Where it means moving towards large, and maybe stupid salimda
which befet Makolo, by…
In this learners any regeneration.
Feel free to read. 5 or 6 years, la ibana saith ha, yim kintukulian mush kelaab taati, mushin gamifications adi mitkun mushkiran habenis valkalamda, ye imna, vi die.
Saha.
I believe the data also may have delay accurate.
And as they initiated data, and the coaxat dashboard,
Yeah, and you can lie about the implications, keto?
best, uh…
for Hallunan, uh…
feedback given… what?
Uh… oh.
Hmm.
regarding…
It has the lessons the area.
Yeah, I mean, yeah.
One love, isn't it?
Where recommendation
We don't have it be a methodology, I will, um…
And formula, and let me share it.
Bishar?
So I'm…
Yeah, and he'll… for kortivia.
Hmm.
So, I will hang it okay.
Uh, but…
How are we fit at the Imah?
We'll come in.
Um, uh, local.
Bogodil mentors del Magudin goal, uh…
El courses at NAFSTO.
Are you… oh.
Um.
will design us to our user experience, go on platforms that nafsta have.
Help with children, Amazon.
Sorry, the Amazon dopamine beta eschok sol rowa
Gen Z.
goal platform.
But yeah, that's an assumption that the invalidated bill case, and OA…
den.
So far, whenever…
Uh, the Rowan, uh…
How about the Chakina…
Amal to you?
Hard
My fish head in Tibet
That might have stopped.i hypothesis.
Okay.
Can you masal lobe video ahead?
How little at our website.
Like in Laoshokvir
missile negatan filoma de lingu lingu.
I observe
But then, if I do points with the notifications, our little dopamine hits,
Weighing, we're engaging, we interactu.
I obviously
AM?
Hello?
I offer.
Was it.
Any feedback? Saraja?
His interviews, cut, uh…
And I'm here specifically in my catchmittellerfil testiben.
deliverably robust, we get hot to any…
Okay.
I will.
Sura.
And el ac aseciertion.
?
A lot of fun.
uh.
essay, Alan?
result in.
I had the ICM o productne.
Our business, our…
Yeah, me, uh…
Feedback, I mean, uh… when?
Damon, el…
But I highly quantitative versus qualitative data.
legal cases, right? Yanni will…
me and Teni…
Yeah, sir, uh, tariff…
Saw Bowling.
group.
Uh…
with you, how the mechanisalhatoske can… okay.
Likely, that's all
Pavanti.
Netaige el me calmet la matihal, die altike length.
Well, I will
inside Clothy B.
How I can treat you inside are any necessary
So how can structure be,
Okay.
In, another badass expectations, Muayanan
With them, as water objectives without the objectives.
Templates, get out of the cargo.
In fundamentals, in principles
Basana Bagar Ismail
Hiya.
Of course, yeah, doctor.
So, at full LA HTML
create hoop soil, they create the template, the coloring.
And a front-end development
However, Workflow SD card. The loss in.
Badul can talk respons
So…
a valid name.
As Bab Kitir,
probably Menil, as Baby Farannel Cherno, el…
When this engagement data, the user Ziani?
kennel ness.
possible, uh…
Reasons, yeah.
Uh…
200 bucks a business ticket.
That's O'Connelly.
So, Kalem Gamish.
having a man.
And, uh, honestly, uh, going to shave.
And into also the demo day, inshallah.
moi.
uh… tip, uh…
I mean, I'm putting them… I gotta…
group output, team output.
Even though in Liltrascott, individuals, individuali…
Fair…
at one point or another, maintain Gretu.
Uh…
When I could honestly shave inni.
I can call the sprint again.
I recorded a sprint to a late.
Uh…
Higher questions.
Then they do outside.
What's so uh
Head.
Oh, my…
After it.
Internship.
You um…
I see? There must be a team-based. We're head.
Messi, my friend.
they'll… they'll assess Manila internspien.
meh.
Hager…
Presentation wahdav.
Faa…
For V, bien el hostile aplicator einem grukon zuyerfil product model.
Let's put the machine, individuals that had the baby, had the echar, uh…
Sprint.
Faire…
have been in.
eh?
And Shufta Bolena il…
And hot the cool little puzzle pieces.
El jagete el mas al…
hypothesis die
root cause tile problems,
But, yeah, holistic output kedom,
If I sprint 2, min,
Again, bordo Colorado detaini.
For that approach.
mesh type. Uh…
El es el motor, ugh,
toast.
Bastian.
Okay.
Okay. The same day…
Um, best hands up.
My time to know.
does not have.
Anna margin
I mean, if he…
en.
In this month individual.
Okay, that, I mean, Mish.
Colosse.
Inshallah.
Uh…
So, I mean, give me mashallah,
I had the Mumbai.
And so…
They have our two agave.
So, crumbs, apparently, ocean.
inshaAllah.
We can sight.
Awesome.